you remember Peter dajiak
I talk about Peter dashak in my fouchy
unmasked series which you can get at
Daily wire plus right now uh it's best
you should especially get it now uh
because uh it goes through the history
of Dr fauci and the corruption in our
Public Health System taxpayer funded and
uh and the corruption that we are still
seeing today in many cases it's getting
worse so Peter daziak
is this Maniac who was uh doing gain of
function research through his group Eco
Health Alliance he was doing
taxpayer-funded Government research on
bat coronaviruses all the sort of
dangerous research that would seem most
likely to be very connected with the
outbreak of the wuflu
and Dr fauci initially denied that he
had ever funded Peter dashak and this
particular kind of research and then he
said that to the United States Senate
then it turned out that was a total lie
that actually we have we have the grand
Dr fauci funded hundreds of thousands of
dollars of research on this kind of
stuff uh to Peter dajik too Eco Health
Alliance so you'd think okay after the
covid thing
this guy's career is over right
certainly he's not getting any more
Government funding
certainly he can't there's a guy who was
doing research at the Wuhan Institute of
virology certainly sure at the very
least this guy isn't not getting
Government funding to do research on
that coronaviruses right
no he just got more money
he just got some more money he just got
653
392 dollars for Eco Health Alliance
Incorporated to begin September 21st
2022 so
20 18 days from now
to do research on
on these sorts of viruses
we we know
that in all likelihood
it was this kind of research that led to
the outbreak of covet according to
Justin B Kinney who's an associate
professor at Cold Spring Harbor
laboratory Princeton PhD he said the
this evidence is not dispositive
but were the lab leak hypothesis
incorrect it would represent a
staggering set of coincidences this I
think is the the biggest
effect of covid this is the biggest side
effect of covid and really certainly the
biggest side effect of the coveted
vaccines coincidences you know just so
many coincidences as a result of all of
this
no consequences here
plenty of coincidence no consequences
even Peter dashek he became it was a big
political issue we raked fauci over the
coals remember Rand Paul grilled Dr
fauci was great it was great TV
it was good stuff I applaud Rand Paul
for doing it for calling attention to
this I I think that my series fouchy
unmasked is very important stuff sheds
all the light on this stuff
but where's the political power
I'm
I'm just a guy with a microphone
I do not currently hold any political
office
maybe I should I don't know I think I
think 2022 is going to be a good year
it's probably a little late to throw my
hat in now but I I can't change the
policy right now
I can just call attention the people who
have political power are the ones that
can change the policy where are they
why can't we do that
I'm not even casting aspersions on the
on the Senators and the congressmen and
in many cases they don't have the power
to do that either because the political
system
is dominated by the libs
even when the Republicans win the house
even when Republicans win the Senate
even when Republicans win the White
House we had Unified Government for a
while under Trump
but we don't control the executive
agencies we don't control the
corporations that have taken more and
more and more power and can literally
wage war and can censor even the
president of the United States
and how did those corporations get all
that power
in part the left let them have it and
part the right the right let them have
it but either way
those guys aren't on our those
capitalists aren't on our side and then
of course the universities and then of
course the media which is just corporate
media anyway and on and on and on it's
very very difficult
in this political
structure to really get anything done
and whenever people pose any threat to
the political structure they get taken
out not AOC she gets invited to the Met
Gala she gets she gets put on the cover
of all the magazines and all the glossy
photos and all the newspapers but when
any ever anyone raises any real
objections to this sort of a system that
person is suppressed
there's no question about it you're
seeing this Dynamic right now the no
consequences Dynamic play out on the
transgender issue there's a high school
in Vermont
it's cracking down right now after
female students complained about a dude
who thinks that he's a woman in the in
the girl's locker room
so girls complain they say look we don't
want to get naked in front of this guy
we don't want this guy getting naked in
front of us that's why we have a girls
locker room right
and the school says okay we're going to
do something about this girls you're no
longer allowed in the locker room
I'm not joking
this is being reported by CBS affiliate
uh WCAX they said okay the way we're
going to deal with this uh transgender
lady you know this guy who who's dressed
up like a lady you get to use the girl's
locker room and the girls on the team
they have to change individually in a in
a single bathroom so they got to take
turns in this one single bathroom to get
changed because they the great fear
would be
you know that this transgender student
we're being bullied by being asked to
leave the girls room and not not get
naked in front of the girls
why is the school doing this
it's not because this is what the
parents want
it's not
it's not because this is popular it's
not public opinion is totally against
this ever if you go out on the street
right now you talk to 100 people 92 of
those people are going to tell you this
is completely insane transgenderism is
bogus certainly at the very least guys
should not be allowed in the girls room
so why is this permitted
because
the ruling class wants it to happen the
people with the power
in in our government
in the corporations in the media in the
press and all over
in in Academia
these people
who have this kind of power they are
pushing transgenderism and why I I
actually have some theories as to why
along the lines of the sort of financial
thesis of today's show uh we don't have
time to get to it right now we we can
get to it at a later date how's that for
a teaser we do have more show coming up
though what we've got to get to is uh a
rap a rap song from a Utah State Senate
candidate a republican Utah State Senate
candidate I have never heard this rap
song before but it's music Monday
so my producer Ben Davies has has lined
up this song for me I can't wait to
listen to it that show is continuing
right now you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member click on the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]